nous entamons ce soir en rendez-vous
hebdomadaire chaque vendredi nous vous
informons sur les travaux en cours
autour du tramway et les perturbations
de circulation actuellement nous sommes
qu'au stade des déviations de réseaux
souterrains à savoir les canalisations
les lignes électriques ou encore les
conduites de gaz si bien que certains
axes sont d'ores et déjà fermé à la
circulation pour un temps déterminé
exemple le secteur du pont volant cette
route qui relie les deux lions a joué
les tours une déviation est mise en
place par le quartier des deux lions
mais il est préférable d'emprunter le
périphérique ouest pour rejoindre
Joué-lès-Tours les travaux doivent
encore durer deux mois et demi une autre
avenue fermée la circulation il s'agit
du boulevard de l'Europe entre la rue
sapailler et le carrefour de la Marne
vous le voyez à l'image déviation mise
en place par les rues sapaillées et
Belgique duraient prévus trois à quatre
semaines il y a d'autres zones
concernées par ces travaux toutes les
informations vous pouvez les retrouver
sur le site internet tram tour.fr